hi in my previous videos I've talked
about dendritic cell and the way of
antigen presenting using class 2 MHC
molecules but in this video I'll be
talking about the cross presentation of
antigens by the dendritic cells so it's
a different kind of phenomena which has
its own benefit so let's look at what is
cross presentation at a cellular and at
a molecular level this is a dendritic
cell and dendritic cell is a
professional antigen presenting cell
that means whether we have antigens
present from a bacteria or virus
dendritic cell would try to phagocytose
those kind of pathogens and take their
antigen in inside and ultimately present
the antigen on top of a class 2 MHC
molecule and this is presented to the
cd4 helper T cells and this is the
normal method of presentation of the
exogenous antigen fight by the dendritic
cell but there there could be under
certain circumstances a different way of
presentation in which dendritic cell
present its antigen on a class 1 MHC
molecule and rather than presenting it
to a cd4 positive helper cell it is
presenting it to a CD 8 positive
cytotoxic T cell now it has its own
consequence and we would discuss about
the mechanism and consequence so stay
tuned till the end of this video now
there are two hypotheses which tells us
why this kind of cross presentation is
important and how it can be done so one
hypothesis tells that there are totally
dedicated
machinery in some dendritic cells that
allow this kind of cross presentation
that is one type of hypothesis but there
is other hypotheses which states that
that this kind of cross presentation is
happening and the antigens that need to
be cross presented is loaded in a
phagosome like vesicles inside the cell
so both these models have their own sub
experimental support behind them but
both of them are
partially correct still what is the
exact mechanism it's unknown now let's
take a look at it so here is a cd4
positive T helper cell and this cd4
positive T helper cell is getting
activated by the MHC bound antigen which
is presented to the cd8 positive helper
T cell by the been retic cell and after
that what would happen this cd8 cd4
positive T cell would actually activate
b-cells and that would secrete
antibodies now let's look at what
changes are happening in the dendritic
cell now in the dendritic cell which is
marked here there could be different
changes for example the dendritic cell
has involves some antigens which is
which is derived from pathogen or nearby
dead cells or anything
now these antigens would be endocytosed
and they would be entering a phagosome
and inside the phagosome they are
generally loaded onto the class 2 MHC
and displayed on the surface but in this
particular case or in special cases in
special type of dendritic cell there
could be certain transporters which
would allow these antigens which are
present in the phagosome to move out to
the cytoplasm there they encountered the
immuno proteasome and the proteasome
degrade those proteins as a result these
degraded protein can enter the
endoplasmic reticulum or even the same
phagosome via Tapp transporter which is
very important for class 1 MHC
presentation and inside the ER the
peptide loading can take place in the
MHC class 1 or inside the phagosome the
peptide loading can take plus take place
on the MHC class 1 and either of these
routes can be chosen to display it onto
the dendritic cell surface and this is
how the dendritic cell which is supposed
to present the antigen on class 2 MHC is
now presenting the antigen on class 1
MHC now you understand what is the
crisscross part of this cross
presentation now people think or there
are experimental evidence
to suggest these cross loading of
antigenic peptides takes place on to the
class 1 MHC inside the phagosome so
phagosome is a super important in terms
of cross presentation now viola cross
presentation the dendritic cell is able
to present its antigenic peptide to the
cd8 positive cytotoxic T cell now what
is the advantage of that this kind of
cross presentation method there could be
certain advantages for example this
particular dendritic cell has sampled a
nearby tissue and found that a
particular tissue has virus infected so
it can sample the antigens from these
viral infected dead cell and quickly
present it to cd8 positive cytotoxic T
cells such that cd8 T cell can take a
quick action and kill those virus
infected cell now this is the most
important advantage of the dendritic
cell presenting a cross presenting the
antigen but cross presenting has also
disadvantages for example it can always
make the dendritic cell more vulnerable
of lysis by the cd8 positive T helper
cell other than that if the dendritic
cell start presenting self antigen on
top of class 1 MHC then there would be a
big mess and there would be the total
breakdown of Tolerance mechanism then
cd8 positive T cell would recognize self
antigens as foreign and it would kill
the cell which is presenting it so it
could be also detrimental so this
process need to be highly regulated
now one thing should come into our mind
that whether this kind of process is
well conserved between all the antigen
presenting cells or it is it only
present in the dendritic cell and it
turns out this kind of process is not
conserved across all the antigen
presenting cells even in terms of
dendritic cell only of my note sub
population of dendritic cell can
crisscross present the antigen as if
this small subpopulation has a license
to cross present okay if this is true
that these subpopulation of dendritic
cell has their presentation license or
cross presentation license then who is
the licensed provider it turns out the
license provider is none other than the
cd8 positive helper T cell the cd8
positive helper T cell recognize the
antigen on class 2 MHC molecule and gets
activated by themselves right and after
activation they want to return the favor
by secreting several cytokines such as
il-2 this il-2 cytokine actually binds
to the specific il-2 receptor on the
dendritic cell and increase its
capability or augments the molecular
mechanism that would help in cross
presentation and that is how cross
presentation is done in case of
subpopulation of the dendritic cell
right this is how dendritic cell
achieves the license to present in the
sub population so we learn in this video
that cross presentation is the ability
of the dendritic cell to present the
antigenic peptides on a class 1 MHC even
though the dendritic cells are trained
to present their antigens on class 2 MHC
but under certain circumstances it is
advantageous for the dendritic cell to
present the antigen on class 1 MHC and
this kind of presentation is known as
cross presentation we looked at its
advantage and disadvantages the biggest
disadvantage it only not only making
itself more vulnerable towards lysis but
also if by mistake it starts presenting
a self peptide then the tolerance
mechanism would be broken and there
could be autoimmune responses in the
body so I hope you enjoyed this video on
cross presentation and the video was
clear if you liked this video give it a
quick thumbs up and don't forget to Like
share and subscribe and do let me know
in the comment how do you like my videos
thank you